so you what's uh we've heard a lot of
stories about Chinese spies coming to
the United States and taking action
against Chinese citizens who are now
living the United States has this has
anything happened to you I mean you're
running for office you're gaining a lot
of influence you believe in Freedom
you're speaking out against the CCP
quite a bit is this something you've
noticed well my last time honestly went
to see my family and friends in China
was 2015. I bought air ticket to go back
2019 but by then I was already big on
social media and going to schools
educated people about horrors of
Communism and somehow they found my
English page and they started to come to
my social media threaten me and said you
bear not ever come back to China so 2019
I wasn't running for anything I was just
educator inspirational speaker so I I
told my husband
he said you better not go back by
yourself because I have to work and we
were getting ready to move to New
Hampshire if you disappear the naturally
they don't look don't let you come back
what I'm gonna do so I wasn't I wasn't
anybody so I was just like small cabbage
you know you know not famous and I said
okay I'll cancel my trip so and now I'm
running as a republican Kennedy and
still be consistent speak out against
CCP when I was giving speech in Utah
near Salt Lake City
one Chinese man showed up in his 30s and
paid 75 dollars take my whole talk then
tell people at the table
you are all been brainwashed by her our
leaders in China are not elected they
are like our fathers so so that people
people told me later lady did he come to
say hi I said no I never met him I don't
know who he is and I tell my Chinese
friends of course his spy don't put your
location on social media so they can
show up and show you and the worst comes
they can attack you so now I say okay
like I I didn't tell people I'm coming
here today tonight until afterwards you
know it's uh well I feel like I have
friends worry about my safety and they
say Don't run for Congress to something
else I say well if I want to make
message to be heard by people in this
country and the Free World even people
who are born this inside the China I'm
the best person to tell the truth and
speak truth to the power just keep that
in mind they've been targeting me and
trying to discredit my campaign and call
me a China spy and and so I was 10 teams
like just believe me me I will never
disappear okay and I will never kill
myself I don't have any mental health
issues can we also get your reaction to
the church shooting that happened in
California from this apparently guy who
I'm reading from the Taipei Times right
now that says the suspect was tied to
approach Chinese
um group and there was this heroic
Taiwanese man he was this Doctor Who Um
rushed the shooter
um this has gotten a lot less coverage
than other mass shootings that have
occurred so could you because the
Chinese against Chinese right well it's
Taiwanese Taiwanese yeah no but they
speak Mandarin regions aren't a monolith
yeah right right they don't report it
what happens is that I'm saying that
they haven't infiltrated into this
country since the Confucius Institute
started like 18 years ago the last one
just closed on campus of University of
New Hampshire like the end of last year
and they were allowed infiltrated in our
schools and colleges to inducted our
children make China look glorious and
also the Chinese newspapers can
distribute to our Congress people in the
Capitol Hill long ago called the
people's daily they pay money to put
their newspaper insert into our
newspaper here in the United States give
to our Congress people and your talk
about infiltration I have a Chinese
human rights activist he almost got
killed in California
recently five Chinese spies were
indicted by doj three were arrested and
one of them is America not even Chinese
so don't don't assume they're just like
look like me they don't they are
everywhere not a few years ago I read an
article there were over 30 000 CCP Spies
all shapes and all colors all people and
there is something to say too about the
amount of Chinese immigrant students
that come here just for a few years and
end up going back and forth for a bit I
know covet did put a little bit of a
dent in that but this is only the spies
that we know about if we can only
imagine how many of these that we don't
so well some of them there are two kinds
of students one come by themselves on
their family only their own money
another kind they sent by the government
and together even unpaid by the
government and they have duty to go back
and to bring all their knowledge so
think about all the potential and
economic expialides working in our
Laboratories and still the secrets from
the high-tech companies and take back to
China and I think the National Security
people are aware of this but it is still
mind you know like confusing to me who
let those people come in here into our
schools into the like a harbor for
example took a lot of money also from
China they did not even report to the
Department of Education you supposed to
report if you take foreign money and now
she's daughter actually went to Harvard
if I'm not mistaken somebody that's okay
well connected right it's interesting
how she didn't choose to go to any you
know Shanghai University she chose
Harvard and they even read cool
challenges called a tenant recruiting
program in the world by and she and they
remember our
um athletes competed for China team
during winter Olympics right right right
yeah and she might even maybe choose do
citizenship even though China do not
allow do certain ship well I don't know
if they're gonna make exception for her
or not and her mom is from China I
thought did she resign like she are she
renounced U.S citizenship to compete for
China or something like that yes one
cool I think yeah strip really bad and
cried
no it was two different girls oh okay
one one recruited by Chinese to compete
for China and she got so much shame she
was crying because she made a mistake
she did not win any medals another one
when the Medal look like a star and get
paid the public 30 million dollars
endorsement money and Mom is from China
who wanted her compete for Chinese team
and you know I I just wonder many many
years later interview them again so what
do you think about China today how are
you trading now I I will not blame her
if she goes by China they're living
there for a few years especially during
his lockdown maybe she works into her
mind already yeah I think it's important
to mention too that athletes and famous
people in China do don't have any
freedom of speech and if they do speak
out in the government in any capacity
people will come for them so one famous
case that's kind of been memory hold is
the case of punctual she's one of the
most famous tennis stars as a household
name there in China she came out with
accusations against one of the party
leaders yes in the Chinese version of
the metoo movement right and she has
been put on lockdown essentially and
like you'll see because there's been a
couple of times where they put her on
camera in the most ridiculous scenarios
I don't know China has not learned how
to you know um prop their videos very
well they do their fake videos very well
but you could tell she's timid
everything's planted and staged and um
Jack ma is also this very famous guy he
was standing there billionaire he was
outspoken for a little bit as China
looked like it was liberalizing a little
bit but then we haven't heard from Jake
ma in Jack ma in years and this was one
of the most famous guys there and nobody
talks about him anymore Jack mods it's
not just celebrities but religious
leaders uh cardinal cardinal Joseph Zen
was just arrested in China I mean this
is this is an extremely high-ranking
person within the Catholic Church
yeah Pope made a deal with Beijing yep
like uh okay in order for the Catholic
Church to exist in China Pope will allow
Beijing to nominate three in like a
bishops for China
maximum three if after three nominations
China is not happy guess what we're
gonna pick one it's all those deals yeah
horrible deal yeah I think the whole
world should stand up firm against CCP
it has been evil and and and conditioned
in Chinese enslave them with their
consent by controlling all the press all
the media or the military all the
natural resources all these schools they
control everything it doesn't matter if
you're building it or not if you say
something criticize China regulator some
stupid economical laws or something
retire donate to charity and do not
travel any threat to the legitimacy of
the government the Chinese government
they will completely yes I saw a great
viral post I forgot the guy so forgive
me for not crediting you but he said you
know how sometimes countries are bad
they get worse and so you flee them to
somewhere safe
imagine now that bad government was the
entire planet and that's globalism
so imagine there's nowhere to go and
that's what's scary about the idea of
Chinese expansion the CCP I'm sorry
that's how I feel I have no place to go
I'm I'm fighting here I'm not going to
be like at my mother who baked in China
before get down on her knees and that's
why I have this that's why I have this
my AR-15
anyway anybody donate 200 you can sign
copy it will mail to you and I'm I'm you
know I I need help I have no place to go
team I don't know where I can go and uh
and I even don't know when I can go back
to China to see my family and friends
and I don't talk to them about the
politics some of them are still
brainwashed to cheer for the regime how
sad is that I have one family relative
tell me to take one minute to remember
cheer my mouth when he had his birthday
in every December your green leader is
gone let's take one minute silence to
remember remember him she had no idea
how many people he started to test he
murdered they still don't know because
that's how they enslave people by
control all they press all the media and
all the propaganda so people still
saying Kumbaya I have a friend who are
locked down for two months in China in
Shanghai and they still tell me don't
don't tell Americans what fine don't say
anything bad we've seen the videos over
the past several years of people
screaming at night when they go out in
their balcony you hear everyone's
screaming they're locked in their homes
there's a photo a guy took his
refrigerator opened it and pushed it on
his balcony because he's got no food
and then and and they're going to act
like everything's okay
like the government is and not only that
our media is also going to act like
everything is okay it's not just them
it's us
well maybe it's it's communist
infiltration yep well that look at what
happened in Australia
what happened in Germany today and what
happened to
um Canada you know the truckers Freedom
um
they have to do this vaccine passport to
travel to to ship goods what's gonna
happen now that those people who lose
their jobs lose their careers and if you
dare not to you know um comply with
radio bank accounts
I think this is zero covet policy in
China also speaks to the fragility and
insecurity of the Communist uh Chinese
government right now they know that even
if there is a small outbreak they do not
have the hospital capacity right now to
deal with any sort of outbreak there and
that will threaten the legitimacy of the
CCP that has been dwindling moreover
they have a cyanovax right now their
vaccine is trash compared to our vaccine
so one plus one for for our
Pharmaceuticals socialist Medicine China
has a socialist medicine I had a friend
entrepreneur wanting to get into
Hospital reform have like a half and
private half or even governmental
Hospital
they destroyed everything he owned he
totally filled on that project almost
just become totally poor again it's
horrible they do they control certain
industries Healthcare is one of them
they do not want you to use a free
market a little bit to to build more
hospitals more clinics later house
doctors prep privately practice no it's
totally regulated so when you have such
a big aging population right people are
getting old and the one child policy
sometimes you cannot even take care of
you like a two both very old parents you
rely on health care but then you don't
have a hospital capacity and now nurses
doctors are going out doing Madness
massive testing testing you know and by
the time you want to go to hospital
they're going to make you wait four
hours until you test is negative to
admit you by the time you're dead I saw
this woman deliver baby without even
anything under her butt a baby came out
on the road because she was waiting for
the test to come back that's four hours
to wait I think he has gone total Math
I'm really worried about my family and
friends and also worry about the world
economy the food supply our supply
chains China poor like Shanghai is 13
about the export you know like Goods
coming out from Shanghai it stopped for
two months that's why people cannot get
their supplies we need to re-look at the
China the market we look at our supply
chains we need to be smart to compete
very you know competitively in the
global economy otherwise what Ronaldo's
totalitarian regions like you rely on
Putin for oil with this weather for oil
instead of drill in your own country and
buy high prices now like Vietnam
Insurance doing is don't you think it's
kind of crazy just don't make sense at
all but they're doing it at the same
time they're sending 40 billion dollars
printed money to Ukraine I hope
Americans who have to pay high prices
gas and diesel in New Hampshire diesels
like 6 6.30 cents per gallon it's
interesting our money or our government
has been spending billions of dollars on
Ukraine the Chinese government has been
spending insane amounts of money buying
corn Futures in the United States
betting on the price of food here to go
up
so that um you know
um who is going to really care about
regular Americans live in this country
and face all those challenges and um I I
know I know it's a false Republican
Democrats vote for this it's kind of sad
for me to say I I I I think that if I do
get elected I probably will join some
Liberty Republicans and and to make some
sense and so we need the people coming
in to vote for the primary vote for
Liberty properties Grassroots candidates
who really will speak for the common
people of this country and then instead
of I don't know who they are speaking to
what they're benefiting are they
benefiting their colonies themselves or
industrial complex or what Lily can I
follow thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there